you grew up in dc yeah the nation i know
that and um
you said you were a news junkie as a kid
which uh some people describe themselves
as an adult as a news junkie i don't
often hear people say i was a news
junkie when i was a kid
yeah describe how much of a news junkie
were you i was a very popular kid first
of all yeah
i imagine super super cool and uh
that guy is a really amazing football
player but that guy knows the news he
knows what's going on like he's trying
to inform the citizenry what a democracy
nerd
so mom comes back to my mom we were in
the car a lot
and we had npr on a lot and the local
station wpfw
black owned radio station out of dc we
watched pbs that wasn't my cable network
it was public broadcasting right
so other kids were like we gotta we're
gonna stay up late and watch some cable
it meant something erratic information
and uh and i guess i got so far so we uh
got the sunday newspaper
and i would read it like cover the cover
it's great the washington post
um my mom had a subscription to this
very nerdy
tech magazine called information week so
i read that too because it was like
around
and uh and when i got bored in class i
would in my earphones
listen to the news instead of the
teacher wow that's how much of a news
junkie i was
right i was the copy aide kind of an
intern role at the washington post
during my summers and even
in the evenings during the school year
did you ever like find yourself saying i
gotta go i've gotta see the evening news
i've gotta leave right now
when i would come home from school i
would race to get home so i could watch
tom brokaw in the nbc nightly dude no
one's ever said that
i'm an original baby i'm an original and
i love tom brokaw no
no dis to tom profile but no one under
70 has ever said
where are we got to get home tom
brokaw's on with the nightly news and
there was no dvr-ing back in the 80s
then no
you really had to catch it live you had
to be there you had to be committed
so uh you grew up in dc and tell me
i'm curious because i know that one of
the
causes that you're interested in is uh
statehood
for d.c something that means means a lot
to you
let's talk about that yeah let's talk
about basic extension of human and
constitutional rights to the residents
of the union which
i'm against okay you knew that when you
came oh yeah but i thought maybe i could
i wanted this to be a healthy debate um
so yeah so let's talk about that because
uh
one of the things that has been
suggested many times is that
dc uh could be a state puerto rico
statehood for puerto rico and this is a
threatening concept
to uh people in this country talk about
that to republican people to white
republican people who don't like the
idea
of black people voting which is why that
party has made it kind of an official
policy to make it very hard for black
people to vote
listen um we in this nation
were so serious about being represented
by our government
that we took the previous government's
tea and dumped it into the harbor
like all the tea and we were close to
britain at that time so i think
americans as they existed
loved tea it was a big sacrifice to take
all that and send king george back and
we had a whole war over taxation
without representation and then in the
seat of power in our own government in
our own nation
we don't extend that to the people of dc
and i take it personally because i grew
up there because my mother grew up there
my father grew up there my grandparents
in many cases grew up there and dc is
full of people
still mostly black people a lot of them
work for the federal government making
all this stuff possible
and you want to take all those benefits
and all those goodies but not let those
people have a real senator we have a
shadow senator
yeah that's like a bad joke right so
let's just
let's on with the democracy let's this
should be an easy this should be a gimme
we can't be
proclaiming democracy all over the world
and denying representation to the people
in our own capital plus the people to
puerto rico it's clear to me that
that and i think to a lot of people that
there's
um fear is driving a lot of decisions
uh in if by people in this country uh
and when i say people i mean
there are people that feel and i think
this has often been the case
historically my way of life is being
threatened
right and um we need to hang on to our
way of life and these are all sort of
coded phrases for we need to hang on to
our power yeah and the demographics in
this country are changing things are
changing
and oh wait a minute parts of the south
are
are voting for uh democrats uh and this
is scary and we're starting to lose our
grip
and so it's fear i think is is is is
that how you see it
i think fear is a great word because a
lot of folks in this country have been
convinced
that the system was great for them
right and that's a story it's a it's a
convincing and compelling story powered
by a bunch of propaganda
like confederate statues as one small
example and a bunch of lies
and the tragedy is that this lie has
lived for so long
that we should hoard all these resources
for a few people that we could tell this
story that
those aren't even people that's what we
convinced ourselves of collectively
they're not even human therefore do what
you want deny them rights kill them
whenever
you want to and so the other side of
that
has also suffered right if you're living
under this lie that you're better than
everybody else then you think everything
you got you just
deserved and worked hard that's a
that's a painful miscalculation and
misunderstanding of how the world works
and i think it limits what we can be
because if folks let go of that fear
we could have a lot more stuff we
talking about this in the podcast and
how to citizen
because i think about it this way people
talk about how great america's been
right we want to go back to the we went
to the moon we defeated the nazis
imagine how much more we could have done
if we let everybody
in right let everybody participate we
could have been to mars
if we let women have bank accounts you
know what i mean like we could have
done so many more greater things with
the greatness that lies in all of our
people
so i understand the fear because i'm a
human being and i know there are things
that i'm holding on to
that i'm afraid to let go of but i also
know from personal experience that when
you face that fear
you let it go it's a great release and a
great relief and it opens us up to the
possibility of something
bigger and better so that's what i hope
for us that's part of what i do what i
do it through all the dark days and
we're living through some darknesses all
the time the pandemic is not a fun time
right what's happening in minneapolis
and across the nation is not fun
but i see the potential to have a
different narrative that isn't based in
that fear you just talked about
you know it's interesting because you're
talking this year on the podcast about
the economy and uh the economic divide
and this is something i think about all
the time and yes
uh you know racial issues and racial
divisions have been
with us since the beginning since the
beginning of this country's uh
you know history has written into our
code yeah it is it is
literally written into the the dna of
our of our
constitution sadly uh and but
what has happened more recently
is the division between the halves and
the half-knots is getting more and more
extreme
it's getting to levels that probably
exceed what we saw in the 1890s you know
the gilded age when
well people thought well that'll never
happen again where you have you have
occasional rockefellers and then
everyone else
has nothing and has to work their entire
life
and and never get out of a slum it feels
like the
people feel the middle class is slipping
away and
this is a big part of what you're
talking about this year on the podcast
absolutely i mean
january 6 was a dramatic moment
in terms of the attack on the capital on
our democracy and if you didn't think we
were divided before then you saw that
you're like oh
i think we're a bit divided and so what
do we do about that do we
talk about bipartisanship vaguely as
some north star
or do we try to dig deeper into what is
at the root of this
and i think it's not an either or thing
the racial
the kind of codification of racial
discrimination
and the excess and the separation of
money and how we've done capitalism here
they're intertwined
we denied labor rights to
certain people as we expanded them for
others the whole union movement was very
segregated
right in the beginning and now we see a
concentration of power handful of a few
companies
grabbing all the goodies a handful of
people owning more than half the people
that's ridiculous
and we have this really perverse
situation where
folks are working really hard one job
two job three job four
and still can't afford their homes
we've heard the argument so many of us
uh the system is rigged
it's winners versus losers winners take
oh i get all that
so what's the other way to do it and
it's it's more democracy dude
like it's more of us showing up it's
being citizens
in an active sense not just in this
legal i was born here
since right when people are afraid you
know to me there's a lot of
obstructionism when people get afraid
they cross their arms and they say
nope nope nope and literally that's
what's happening in the filibuster
that's happening that's what a lot of i
think mitch mcconnell is about is no
no no no not even he's not the part that
i um
i so sometimes want to like vilify all
republicans
right and then i have to check myself
yeah
and i look at the numbers and you look
at you know this voting
anti-voting situation in georgia
the majority of the people of georgia
didn't want that either right
there's a in some cases it's literally a
handful of people
who are overriding the will of the
people yeah
as pseudo-duly elected representatives
who chose their voters more than their
voters
got to choose them because of
gerrymandering and all these other
shenanigans
and they're forcing things down the
people's throat
so we all have to wake up i do look
forward to a real debate with an
actual republican if we could find one i
don't think mitch mcconnell is actually
representing them
many of the time sometimes he is and i
will disagree with that too
but a lot of times what the leadership
is doing isn't reflective of what the
people want
right and that's exactly how we got
ourselves into the situation in the
first place that's why we put that tea
in the harbor
because those leaders were not
responsible to or representing what the
people wanted yeah
i saw the other day this uh clip
online and it was this uh it was charles
barkley
and he said in his heart he really
believes most people are good
uh he thinks that it's there are people
in this country who can divide us
by and he said to be fair on the right
and the left there are people that can
divide us by just getting us
whipped up on hating the other side it
helps polarize us
and we can't get anything done and he
actually felt like there was more we
could accomplish
that we're not as far apart as we think
we are and i thought that was a very
hopeful message
you know and it's true there's an
organization called beyond conflict
and they have worked in literally
war-torn societies all over the world
for decades
and the aftermath of civil wars that's
real division
when folks are taking up guns and
machetes and lobbing ieds at each other
right okay so they have done studies
there and practices to bring folks
together and what they found here in the
u.s
is that we're not as divided as we think
we are and the way they did it they
asked
for example democrats what do you think
republicans think of you
as a democrat and on a scale of one
they hate me ten they want to marry me
and have all my babies
they're like democrats oh they feel a
one toward me they want to destroy me
right and then they said republicans
what do you think of democrats
and i was like i don't know four yeah
yeah you know
right it's like there's a gap there's a
distortion there's a perception
distortion and that's where leadership
matters yeah that's why i was so excited
about joe biden who i was i was not
writing for joe biden
i was more of a bernie type of person
right and
but i respected joe biden's awareness of
his power to lead
by language by example by channeling
what's in all of us there's good in all
of us
yeah there is bad in all of us
and someone can pull one level or the
other
and whip us into that frenzy that you
talked about or
they can say hey that person's kind of
similar to you
yeah i think we might be in this more
together than a part
why do we play that part up right and uh
so yeah we're it's not as bad in some
cases as it seems
it is still real and it is and that's
the kind of the complexity it's like i'm
not trying to say
we're already united everything's great
it's not great
yeah it just isn't and to be famous and
to be fair i've there's stuff i
make it a practice to i will tune in to
fox to see what they're saying oh bless
you
um well i just i want to support them in
any way i can you have a timer
or what's the how do you manage this
it's a feeling you get inside uh it
helps me digest
i do tiny doses you know what i do dose
lsd i have dose foxes yeah
micro micro dose of fox news is terrific
it
uh it raises the uh the blood pressure
in a way that's quite healthy yeah
um no i like to see i like to flip
around and see how different
people are covering the same story and
i'll get irritated when i see
sometimes cnn doing the same thing or
msnbc doing
a version of what they're doing on fox
news just the opposite tact
and harping on the negative and i think
i do think sometimes that yes there's
money in the extremes there's money to
be made in the extremes and the money
is in extreme opinions on the left and
on the right
and that's what whips people into this
negative state
sometimes which bums me out and i think
it's also a lack of imagination on the
part of people trying to make that money
right you look at social media which has
turned us all up to 11.
and how it amplifies disagreements and
there's profit
in that and it's laziness right there's
there's a different algorithm
which doesn't have us grabbing
pitchforks trying to stab the other
person in the eye
yeah they just stumbled on the cheap one
first
i think yeah certainly hope it's the
first thought yeah not this
like the best thought it's the easy
thought yeah and it's like let's evolve
let's do better than that maybe let's
have more people involved who are
impacted by these systems in the first
place
again democracy there i go you know the
people having power and a say over the
systems that influence them
that's the ticket through most of this
stuff right
it was funny i was driving to work
yesterday
and this truck drove by me and it was
like the guy was honking his horn
i mean just in general at anybody and he
had a giant flag
and the flag said socialism sucks
and and uh exclamation point and this
flag coming out in out of his car and i
thought
who's forcing socialism on you like i
think socialism for this guy is a
buzzword for
anyone who doesn't agree completely with
his narrow agenda
is socialism i i kind of wanted to run
him off the road and say
explain socialism to me and he probably
wouldn't be able to
socialism is the uh the public hospital
he gets taken to
after you run him off the road right
exactly and we have to deny that service
if you hate socialism wait a minute is
this for free yes
forget it send that stimulus check back
too
and also while you're at it get off this
public roads yes exactly
socialist demonstration of engineering
i don't want anybody fixing these roads
that's [ __ ] yeah